The Banana Lounge is a space on campus that
students can grab a banana, grab a drink,
they can study, they can rest. It's basically
a space that is meant to bring people together,
people in the MIT community
[Music] I'm Megan Lim and I am
currently logistics lead of Banana Lounge. My team
works on a lot of the operational side of things,
so there's ordering the bananas, there's ordering
of the drinks and all the other consumables.
Just yesterday we went through 53 banana boxes
and each banana box has about 100 banana fingers.
Right now it's being funded by UA and
alumni donors, which we really appreciate.
The volunteers care about the space a
lot and also care about helping others.
Why bananas? There's quite a lot of good
reasons, it's very, something light hearted
that we appreciate and that hopefully
the MIT community appreciates as well
I heard about the Banana Lounge before I even
stepped foot on campus. Every time I step in
the space like there's usually at least one
person, especially during the busy hours,
there's like people, someone you know like hey,
haven't seen you in a while, or what are you doing
here again at 2am in the morning? I think it's
really important that it's student run, like no
one knows students better than students and that's
what makes the place really unique to me because
like people that benefit it is people like myself,
people who struggle with psets, people who are
just looking for a community. Students are active
all times of day, and if students need a space to
grab a banana, grab a drink or like a pick-me-up,
then that's what we want to be for them. It will
be open 24/7. Sometimes at 2am you need food
and Banana Lounge will be there for you. There's
a wide variety of people at MIT and Banana Lounge
wants to support those people. They want to study
late at night, let them study late at night, they
want to play with Legos late at night, let them.
I see someone walking around with
a banana I know that that person
just visited Banana Lounge, and it makes me smile